a court in New York has heard closing
arguments in a civil lawsuit accusing
Donald Trump of rape and defamation the
former president denies the claims which
have been brought by former L magazine
advice columnist Eugene Carroll well
let's get more on this we can speak to
our U.S correspondent James Matthews in
Washington uh James what's been said
what's been said by the attorneys for
Eugene Carroll Donald Trump's accuser is
that she has presented credible
consistent and Powerful evidence around
an incident she says took place in 1996.
she says that she met Donald Trump
outside a department store in New York
they ended up inside he had asked her
for advice in buying a gift for a woman
they were in the lingerie department
they went went into a dressing room and
it's inside there that she says she was
raped by Donald Trump he dismisses it
points to the fact that she made these
Revelations many years after the alleged
incident took place he says she was
trying simply to sell a book calls her a
hoax said that these are false
accusations against a rich guy in the
closing arguments by her attorney
she presented video evidence the video
deposition of Donald Trump he didn't
give evidence in court in person but he
was asked questions on video now this is
a man who said he'd never met his
accuser and that in any case she wasn't
his type the attorney for Eugene Carroll
said well look at the video here's a
photograph that has Donald Trump in the
same frame as e Gene Carroll and when
presented with this Photograph on video
Donald Trump confuses his accuser with
his second wife Marla Maples according
to the attorney for aging Carol that
shows that she was very much his type
look at the video
there's like Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing to I
know here
oh the person you just pointed to
was ocean Carroll who is that who is
this point
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry
there you go the jury is due to be sent
out in this case tomorrow it's very
important for all concerned not least
the woman at the center of an e Gene
Carroll significant for Donald Trump
bear in mind he's already facing charges
in connection with hush money payments
to a porn star he's also fishing facing
criminal investigations into other
matters related to the mishandling of
classified documents and into events
surrounding the January the 6th
Insurrection if a jury finds in favor of
his accuser and he successfully sued
that would cost him a lot of money it
would be also a hefty addition to the
legal burden that he carries